Hey, this is funny.
So many of you know this guy named Jesse Lee
Peterson.
He's a 70 year old black religious conservative.
I've been on his show.
I've appeared in his studio in Los Angeles
at his Christian men's counseling center.
Yeah.
When I was last in Los Angeles or not last
actually a couple of times ago, maybe it was
last time.
Now I don't even remember.
It's all blur.
Uh, he was recently, either he was interviewed
by or he interviewed another conservative
Trump has named Nick de Paolo.
And if you've not heard of Nick DiPaolo DePaulo,
I don't know how he pronounces the last name
a Nick DePalo is a 57 year old Trumpist comedian
from the Boston area.
Shockingly enough.
And the topic came up when they were talking
to each other of apparently Jesse Lee Peterson
seems to think that he and I are debating
at Politiken this weekend.
Now I'll talk more about that in a second.
And they took it as an opportunity, I guess,
to frame me as some idealistic, wide-eyed,
naive, 18 year old political correctness,
socialists, lefty or something like that.
Take a look at this clip.
Well, he's actually gonna be a debating a
David Pakman at a Politiken
on October 27th in Nashville.
Please welcome, uh, Jesse Lee Peterson.
Jesse, how are you all those, well, thank
you so much for having me, Michael.
Appreciate it.
My pleasure, Jesse.
I got away, I said earlier, I'm really liking
the studio.
You and Lou Sharpie the background.
Yeah.
I'm not a, I'm not good with my hands, but
we, uh, we found the cheap place where I could
save about two grand a month and me and my,
me and my producers were at home Depot, uh,
you know, all weekend buying plywood and two
by fours and somehow we got it all together,
eh?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we love it much better actually.
It's uh, it's more intimate and uh, yeah,
I'm, I'm actually proud of people saying nice
things about it.
Let me ask you just see, uh, uh, first things
first.
Uh, who's this guy you debating and do you
need help?
Cause he sounds like a punk.
No, I'm just kidding.
Who, who's David Pacman?
You know, I've had them on my TV show, the
fallen state.tv.
I believe we've been on a radio show or something
like that.
He's just another little young liberal who
has no idea of what he's doing or what he's
talking about.
He's one of those intellectuals who, who has
no sense of common sense at all.
So I'm trying to help him find his way back
home.
It's a nice way of putting it.
How did these, how do these kids get so luck
kids, I'm, well, I'm 57.
I guess I can say that.
How do they get so lost Jesse today and why
are they so susceptible to a lot of this,
uh, left wing PC garbage culture?
They seem to ingest it.
I know it goes back to college campuses and
even further back a high.
How do you undo that?
How are you going to get this guy home?
Well, it's, it's really due to the lack of
fathers.
Well, you don't have a, a father and a mother
who are perfect examples for you.
If the father is not the head of his wife
and the children, then the mother tend to
take over and women tend to be emotional.
And so the boys and girls are turned away
from the father.
And so they take on the, uh, the thoughts
and ideas of, uh, of their mothers and the
feelings.
So when they go out into the world, it's easy
to deceive them because they are, uh, women
tend to be intellectual and men tend to be,
uh, logical.
It's also funny to me what when you watch
something like this, Nick DePaulo seems to
be talking to Jesse Lee Peterson.
Like Jesse Lee Peterson is a serious political
person, which is just precious and hilarious
and it's not the approach I've taken when
I, when I, uh, do stuff with Jesse, but you
know, left wing political correctness, that's
not this show.
That's not me.
That's never what it has been.
Uh, how to get me home.
They want to figure out a lack of a father.
I have a father and there's no, no problem
there.
And hilariously, if you looked at the live
chat while they were broadcasting this, the
comments aren't just about me being, you know,
girly man feminized Cissy liberal as the problem.
A lot of the people in the live chat were
saying, no, no.
The problem with David Pakman is he's one
of these jewel liberals.
That's a the real problem.
Anyway.
Clearly society is going to progress as a
result of the political discourse that happens
when a 70 year old and a 57 year old make
fun of a 35 year old who isn't even there
to defend himself, uh, on the basis of incorrect
allegations.
Right?
This is really how we're gonna solve the world's
problems.
Now let's get to the political thing.
I am confused about why Jesse Lee Peterson
believes that he's debating me at Politiken.
I'm not going to political.
I have no tickets to Nashville.
I have a weekend of, uh, uh, social and family
gatherings planned.
People have notified me that Politik on, on
their website listed an event that, uh, shows
me debating Jesse Lee Peterson, I think on
Sunday at like three or 4:00 PM.
And I have no idea why my manager was in discussions
with Politiken.
We never got an offer in writing with all
of the parameters and logistics that had sort
of been mentioned, uh, verbally.
And they have it scheduled for a time Sunday
afternoon, where even if I were to go, um,
I wouldn't be able to do it at that time.
We had problems getting the travel together.
I was waiting around for a written offer for
something like six weeks.
In any case, nothing happened.
I was never going to Politiken never had flights
to Nashville, never signed a contract.
Um, there's actually, I'm kind of being careful
because there's actually a lot more to this
story.
I don't think it's appropriate for me to tell
it right now, but much like Sam Cedar had
a story to tell about Politiken and he waited
nearly a year to tell that story.
He recently told it.
It relates to Steven Crowder.
I also have a story to tell about Politiken,
um, which maybe I will someday tell, but not
today.
And I, a lot of my friends are going to Politiken
and participating and I don't want to get
anybody in trouble, throw anybody under the
bus or do anything.
Uh, but there is a story to tell.
In any case, I was never going to Politiken.
I will not be there.
I'm not debating Jesse Lee Peterson.
I have no idea what he will be doing or what
he thinks he will be doing.
It's, it's all kind of a nebulous, uh, very,
uh, sort of opaque situation.
But I will not be at Politiken for everybody
who's been emailing me and asking about it.